with this chapter we've got to kind of
fancy words that when you looked at out
of the probably some why these things
mean and he's not worth it oxy and what
did you think probably first right off
the bat Eastern Orthodoxy because right
can you talk about the Eastern Church
neo-orthodoxy is not connected with
Eastern Orthodox as well as you read on
you realize that Hindu it Protestants
and then we're going to look at acute
Menace ISM this is a word you might have
Turner it's depending on you know what
sort of religious background yeah or
here if you go to inter church dialogues
or interfaith dialogues that's an
example of that kinetise ISM so that
became something popular that became
something important in the last you know
half century or so so let's talk about
neo-orthodoxy first a little bit of
Rivia we've talked in previous chapters
about the rise of christian
fundamentalism and fundamentalists
interpose themselves to modernist who
would usually not call themselves
modernist but liberals we're talking in
terms of the social gospel what were the
real dividing issues that broke up
churches is remember the fundamentalist
in the modernist state they had these
battles within churches over who would
actually control things one of the big
issues is evolution the theory of
evolution coming down from Darwin that
said that human beings well there are
really a few different factors one was
you know could the biblical creation
story be literally true if evolution is
true you have to pick one or the other
right even if you say well God started
evolution God would have had to start an
evolution along long ways back the other
thing that they were really worried
about was social Darwinism this notion
that it was survival of the fittest and
you know that's not like a pad
the Christian worldview were message or
social ethic biblical scholarship
critical scholarship had begun to show
that these texts of the Bible did not
come down you know verbatim from some
mouth and the cloud saying write this
down but rather they had gone through
processes of editing they were
conditioned by the cultures of the time
they were written at different times so
you know single books might actually
have a couple different people writing
bless you and writing and incorporating
things over the course of time like the
Book of Isaiah for example some books
actually you know that they hadn't been
written by different people like the
Psalms because it'll say psalm of David
the psalm of Solomon Solomon this guy
but you know a lot of people have the
view that the Bible is just like one big
book that came directly from from God
himself and you know saying to them well
that's not what scholarship reveals that
kind of blow a lot of people's minds so
well that was a key issue and then the
social role of the church
what should the church be doing in
modern industrial society that has a lot
of inequalities it has a lot of
historical baggage associated with it
these are questions that are still being
asked today so the fundamentalists and
the
modernists were sort of at the Antipodes
and neo-orthodoxy it's kind of a
mediating position between the two of
them in a way it's rejecting what it
sees as wrong it's criticizing what it
sees in wrong in both of them so for
example on the question of biblical
scholarship the neo Orthodox would say
look you fundamentalist you're taking a
very uncritical naive attitude towards
the biblical texts that's not going to
work but you modernists you're also
going to
far with some of your your idea of some
of your claims your you know going
beyond what what evidence would suggest
and this is sort of the battle that's
still going on today with respect to the
social role of the church they said the
church traditionally as the community
the Christian community was involved in
taking care of people it was involved in
transforming society blood you're not
going to be able to create heaven on
earth it's a way that some of these you
know liberals and social gospel people
seem to think you're going to have
problems arising in any sort of any sort
of organization that's trying to to make
things better you know an example of
this would be if you think about unions
well you know what was the purpose of
unions originally why do people make
them just cuz they wanted didn't have an
Elks Club to go to and you know more
funny do that people that you work with
actually I mean actually work with the
people you might not want to see them on
your time off yeah wasn't it like to get
like a group of people who like all one
of the same things about they have like
numbers behind like to get what they
wanted yeah why did they do that what
was the situation that they're coming up
in terms of like you know job conditions
just like job security and that their
rights are being protected yeah maybe if
you look at what it was like for workers
in eighteenth and nineteenth centuries
in industrial England America Germany
France it's pretty horrific not as
workers
coal miners Cowboys with its romantic
image of
you know agriculture that really wasn't
the case
working socks in a lot of cases and if
your employer can explain to you that
makes it even worse
and so unions form so unions were a good
thing that's one thing they actually
brought about up a lot of lasting social
changes that helped out people and we
receive some of the benefits of comes
with suffering and toil but they engaged
in jet you know decades and generations
ago our union is always a good thing so
some people shaking their head why not
by the 1960s and 70s they've gotten
connected with organized crime nobody
thinks organized crime is a good thing
despite the fact that we romanticize you
know the Mafia other organizations
sometimes unions actually don't don't
protect their members sometimes they act
like any other organization and
just sort of take advantage of the
people under them union bosses become
the new factory owners you've got to be
careful about this or stuff that's the
sort of thing that the Neal were that I
should focus on they would say look any
one human institution that you think is
going to save the day and it's going to
fix everything you've got to be very
careful about that the people who if we
talk in terms of the westerns and the
white hats and black hats or you guys
remember this terminology the old
westerns you could tell it was a good
guy because he wears a white hat bad guy
wears a black hat well the me Orthodox
would be saying the white hats and black
hats change over time guys who start out
as a white hat eventually it becomes
gray as they start cutting corners I
think why do they do this well it's a
explicitly Christian thing a lot of
these neo Orthodox talked quite a bit
about the effects of original sin this
traditional Christian notion that you
you can take human beings and human
beings are not bad in and of themselves
but there's some radically screwed up
things about us there's there's ways in
which were broken to the core and we're
not the way that we ought to be and so
when you put a bunch of human beings
together in an organization that
organization is not going to make them
somehow better than they are and this is
going to have some effects your book
talks about some of the that really key
thinkers involved in this and one of
them his name is Karl Barth still very
highly regarded today he was a swiss
german writer in the reformed tradition
and he wrote this this set of books
called church dogmatics he also wrote a
lot of other stuff too including a book
on a guy who I particularly like Anselm
of Canterbury so this guy had an
incredible range and Bart was reacting
against the modernism and liver
of his time he he said New Testament
scholarship was like going too far how
many of you've heard of Albert
Schweitzer before anybody that's an
empty name to you now this were a couple
generations ago people had heard of him
trite sir was known for being a great
humanitarian but he also wrote a book
about the quest for the historical Jesus
and what he was doing was what we call
historiography are any history majors in
here his history in historiography are
two connected but different sentence
historiography is the history of history
so people write history books right and
over time yeah that's historiography
yeah it's tough to do with things that
are where you've only got a few decades
to work with it's easy to do like the
historiography of ancient historians cuz
there's plenty of them out there and he
could see what's going out of your time
but in any case what Schweitzer was
doing is he's looking at all these
people that are writing books about
Jesus and in the nineteenth century
there had been quite a few and
interestingly these books didn't all say
the same thing they would they would
take off from the biblical texts and
then if they found new tax they would
incorporate those anything that said
well you know this guy Jesus the
Christians have actually misunderstood
him he was actually a like a liberal
social gospel kind of guy and Schweitzer
said it's sort of like everyone's
looking down a well
trying to find Jesus at the bottom the
trouble is when you look down well what
are you actually gonna see in the water
if you see anything
of yourself exactly so all these people
are looking down the years and the Jesus
that they're seeing is that Jesus that
they want to see who you know ends up
being kind of a you know bourgeois nice
guy Jesus and so Bart says you know if
you actually take the gospel serious
that's not what you're going to get if
you're not projecting your own desires
on to it and you're letting the gospel
sort of speak to you then you're gonna
get a really weird Jesus Jesus who Ben
flicks with what it is that you would
like to see down there and then you have
a choice you have to make are you gonna
follow it your own desires or are you
going to actually go with the revelation
that that's there and Bart himself is
taking off then your book talks about
some of the people that really
influenced him like st. Augustine Luther
Calvin but also this guy sir and
Kierkegaard is a Danish theologian and
philosopher somebody else who had
particularly liked as well and Bart
gives rise to this whole movement of
what's called dialectical theology a lot
of that is coming in out of character
garden sometimes you'll hear this talked
about in terms of existentialism
existentialist theology so Bart's not
the only guy who's doing this there's
another guy in the scene later on Paul
Tillich who is here in the States as a
matter of fact if you if you could you
take an existentialism class you might
actually read Paul Tillich's book the
courage to be able till it was a major
American theologian was well he's a bit
more liberal than Denmark was somebody
else or rather two guys who are very
important and really fit into this the
niebuhr brothers Reinhold
and Richard and Richard is more of a
church historians you run a particularly
good one called the kingdom of God of
America up appearances Ronald was more
of the heavy-hitter theologian social
social theorist and he still highly
regarded baby today look that you might
have read by him if you've ever read
anything by him a moral man an immoral
society it's a very easy read and well
worth worth looking at and Reinhold
Niebuhr like he's the book says begins
his career as a pastor in in Detroit and
in Detroit he had a chance to see the
inequities in the social order in race
and Labor Relations and he saw how
Christians are trying to to deal with
this sort of stuff
he eventually you know starts moving
upstairs so to speak in the hierarchy of
education yam then he becomes nationally
prominent as an applied Ephesus and he
levels this profound criticism of
American institutions from the social
gospel you know to to all sorts of other
things and he's saying things like it's
you know you don't want to say shouldn't
have an economy and you don't want to
say you shouldn't have politics but
don't pretend like the kingdom of God is
actually going to be realized here on
earth through some political platform
and if you are actually trying to make
claims like that you're probably
engaging in idolatry and so you know
fundamentalists could say yeah I think
you're right about that sort of stuff
but they they wouldn't go along with him
on other things modernists and
theological liberals who were often very
prone to read into their social Crusades
it kind of eschatological significance
also couldn't go along with that either
he was criticizing them he ends up
actually becoming pretty important in
American politics the influencing people
like John Kennedy so
now a needle worth photography ends up
sort of vanishing from the scene after a
while it gets supplanted by some more
radical theologies in the 60s and 70s
but it came back to a certain extent in
these 90s and it's kind of the
background of a lot of contemporary
theological writing a lot of
contemporary theological thinking so
it's good to know about the next thing
we want to talk about is thank you
mantis ISM so what does this term active
medicine what does that mean if you're
acting medical is there something wrong
with you
maybe disease you can take a pill for so
Mike you medical or is it a good thing
why can't you be a key medical like your
brother
it's not really either one of those sort
of things it has to do with with how you
relate to let's let's put it in terms of
enter two things from the dialogue this
is a key issue that's faced by anybody
who belongs to a community that has some
very strong beliefs that has a history
that has tradition behind it and that's
differentiated from other communities
and it doesn't just have to be a
religious issue
in terms of politics it could be in
terms of your reviews on academia and
whether it's worth going to college or
not or whether you should you know go
get a quote real jobs out there the
world right away
people have very strongly held views on
some things right and quite often people
stick with people who see things the
same way as though ecumenism means
broadening your horizons so that you
actually engage with people who don't
see things the way that you do so let's
think in terms of that well let's get
away from religion so we can use a
different example everybody here in this
classroom except for me and at one time
I actually put the bill to is a pretty
traditional college student you guys are
in your late teens very few of you or
early 20s you have some sort of career
track in mind and thank all of you plan
on working after this good job for you
out there that'll suit your heart's
desire but at least you're set to do
things like that
what would be the what would be somebody
else's wife position which would be
radically different than yours where not
only would they have different desires
and different sub plans different
outlooks different expectations but they
would also like you you guys spend a lot
of time with other college students
don't you but you know whether you like
it or not you have to you're in class
with them you live in a community with
them you have to interact with them do
you think of yourself as a college
student
what would be another example for
somebody to be 12 let's say 22 years old
where they would be in that kind of
circumstance living with a lot of other
people who are doing the same thing as
them seeing the world the same way
that's radically different from your own
current lifestyle
what comes to mind
yeah that's the first thing I thought
about - now of course we know higher OTC
students have you know kind of living in
two different worlds sometimes makes it
tough doesn't it but yeah if you're over
in Afghanistan and you're you know
hanging out with them the people in your
squad your platoon your company you may
not even know the people in your
Battaglia because you know you never see
them and you're doing that day in day
out that's a very different kind of life
experience than what we have here isn't
it would you have anything in common
with them other than being Americans or
you know maybe popular culture did you
catch the show last night you know you
like that what do you like for the
Superbowl
what do you a life stuff imagine you
were gonna write a letter to them or you
know would be a lot easier to email all
right who writes letters these days so
you're going an email you're gonna do
one of these email a soldier program
what would you actually say to them how
would you connect with them how was your
day I say well roadside bomb today and I
think I'd have killed somebody but I'm
not sure because I was shooting at them
and they're about 400 yards away and I'm
not sure how I feel about it
yeah my day was like that - I took a
test and Mayo's that test heart or is it
impossible to relate to people of these
kind of circumstances yeah I mean like
in fall situations like there's like a
goal in mind okay
so notice what you're doing there you're
looking for commonalities that bridge
over the differences and you're not
saying the differences don't matter that
would be this sort of snarky thing that
I was doing you know I know exactly how
you feel what are you a lot of them's we
have no idea how other people feel but
that doesn't mean that we can't engage
in dialogue with them now let's go back
to the realm of religion imagine that
you're a Catholic you grew up Catholic
and you didn't grow up in the very
multicultural society that we have and
so you grew up and the sort of
Catholicism of 1930s 40s 50s which has
been described yes here comes everyone
meaning that everybody you know in your
neighborhood is a Catholic because you
probably live in a you know Catholic
area in the city of that area maybe you
go to Catholic school odds are if your
parents have enough money or the priest
is active enough in your parish you
probably go to Catholic school you don't
go public and now you go to the
workforce and you start interacting with
people and one of them is a Baptist and
one of them is a Jew and one of them is
a Pentecostal and you start realizing
wow people don't all take this for
granted and when I you know this isn't
something that most people do these days
but when I make the sign of the Cross
before I say grace before meals everyone
looks at me funny like I'm doing
something wrong or weird now you're in a
situation that could call for a few
medicine and what was going on in
America the end the 20th century was a
lot more and more Documenta sysm as your
book says it begins really the
ecumenical movement begins within the
Protestant community why the problem and
why did that be though the place yeah
to a lot of information yeah by the time
that we're talking about the early 20th
century the Protestant Reformation is
splintered into you know hundreds of
different approaches to what it means to
be a Protestant Christian and sometimes
they've actually no not here in America
so much but in other places fought Wars
about it so you know some of them take
take these things pretty seriously and
they begin to start you know comparing
and contrasting and seeing whether they
can overcome some of these divides and
your book talks about a number of
different examples of this the
Unitarians and Universalists come
together in one church the
Congregationalists become more and more
liberal over the years they unite with
the Christian churches the United Church
of Christ forms out of the ecumenical
movement Methodists and Presbyterians at
one time we're divided you know into
North and South because of slavery the
civil war broke them apart the churches
come back together your book also talks
quite a bit about the Evangelical
Lutheran Church in America which is the
result of a whole bunch of mergers
taking place over decades between all
these different with your bodies and
that's all coming out of the ecumenical
movement there's a number of different
councils of churches that they come
about the Federal Council of Churches
the National Council of Churches and the
idea is to try to bring people together
without that trying to road the
differences without trying to make them
all into one thing to bring them
together so that they can always talk to
each other and perhaps share some sort
of community with each other your book
then it talks about what happens among
other other Christians and indeed other
religions outside of the Protestant
spectrum
it says interfaith dialogue among the
Eastern Orthodox Roman Catholic and
mainline Protestants are now is now a
common place
American religious life and it says
fundamentalists and some evangelicals
keep their distance evangelicals have
actually in recent years there's an
evangelicals and Catholics together
movement that publishes things every
once in a while they got together and
they talked about their differences
about say marry in recent years and so
there's a lot of discussion along these
lines that's that's occurring there have
been some attempts to try to leverage
this into actually producing some sort
of community so your book gives the
example of the churches uniting churches
uniting Christ which used to be in the
consultation on church Union that's why
I was thinking koku yeah the idea was to
actually bring all these churches
together these sort of things usually
don't get a lot of traction because
there's something interesting to think
about why do people go to the churches
that they do I mean
America's are like a huge marketplace if
you decided that you weren't getting
what you wanted all the church that
you're currently going to you could go
to another church right just look in the
yellow pages online you know or if you
go to a hotel you can you know usually
better hotels on the listing of all the
local religious bodies so that people
can go to them why do people go to the
particular churches that they go to
there's a question a lot of people don't
think about yeah
okay now notice those can be two very
different things because you could
actually love what your church stands
for and be like man people running up
they have no idea what they're doing I
you know I go for the Liturgy but I
can't stand these you know people in
charge or it could be the other way
around I don't really like the liturgy
but I kind of like these people that are
running a show you know they seem to
have good you know good things in mind
so there's two things right there are
two considerations those are probably
good reasons to go to church what are
other reasons people go yeah yeah and
sometimes it'll be like well look our
families always go onto this church not
it may not even be just the denomination
you know there could be like two two
churches of the same denomination within
driving distance we're not going to that
church because our family's never gone
to that church it's got to be this
church over here and you're like they're
both in the same denomination it's not
supposed to make any difference but
people have these kind of emotional
attachments to that people go to
churches because they have some sort of
intrinsically valuable reason at some
level to go to that church to belong to
that group to continue in that tradition
otherwise they'll find another one if
you try to bring them all together into
one huge umbrella and say well we're all
on the same page what do you think the
effect of that sometimes is people
stopped being interested they start
saying what's the point
we lost what's distinctive to us well
let me ask you and this will sound like
a very silly trivial question but I
notice a lot of us would have MERIS
spirit gear do you have any sort of
emotional attachment to that what if the
mayor has decided everyone's going to
have to turn in you know you have to
turn in that shirt
you know the swimming show too you know
and we're going to give you a blue and
yellow one instead of you yeah it sounds
fine to me colors or colors or would
that bother you on someone even though
even though it's totally irrational with
that Bobby bothered me I don't even go
here I just teach here they wouldn't
would it bother you what if they said
when I threw the Fox anymore we're now
going to be the Warlock poor love the
pale or the you know there's a lot more
there's very few foxy ground here we're
using markers let's take a marker and
let it have a tail you know just keep
some continuity the fighting markers
will they bother you what is it just
because it's silly that it would bother
you or do you have an emotional
attachment you want something that's
distinctive yeah my friend that goes to
a school in central Pennsylvania and
they've always been like the Crusaders
oh yeah we're they're like a living
thing and then that they never like had
an actual mascot recently those because
I guess that was a little like tough to
make a mascot for so yeah so they didn't
really have it's uh been a head like the
tiger at their games or get enough
tigers but then they just changed it and
I guess since they have a lot of
squirrels on their campus they're now
like there's two other Crusaders but
they're gonna have squirrel up their
canes
how's that gonna go in there is really
good know it just because of it so you
know this is about sports stuff right
which it which really are the big
pictures can't reveal stuff now extended
supervision are people's emotions and
long-standing commitments are even more
involved if you try to Road religious
differences sometimes that drives people
away and that's what brings us to talk
now about mainline Protestantism